invité de sao qu'a dit ce matin
geneviève d'eau vous êtes pour la
coordinatrice du téléthon pour la
martinique bonjour geneviève d'eau
jusqu'à samedi bonjour je donne tout bon
jour
jusqu'à samedi minuit aux sols numéro le
36 37 pour faire des dons en 2015 250000
euros ont été récoltés et dandy relier
un peu plus de 225 milles des dons en
baisse comment vous expliquer cela eh
bien écoutez vous avez quand même les
martiniquais sont restés très généreux
cependant ils sont tous aussi concernés
par la crise et malgré les difficultés
je j'ai envie de dire les martiniquais
doses allant de 126 je veux dire c'est
quand même une peut-être au niveau du 36
37 mais sur le plan local avec la force
t nous avons quand même été en train en
progression de 78 milles je crois nous
sommes quand même passés à 90000 euros
l'année dernière en force t et la force
t ce sont toutes les manifestations
c'est la mobilisation des écoles de tous
les partenaires de tous les défis qui
ont lu sur place donc pour être objectif
je dirais que nous sommes quand même en
évolution léman tiken démérite pas ils
s'intéressent à la cause puisque la
force t augmenté l'an dernier la
première est qu'ils sont pas trop
solliciter les martiniquais est ce que
ça fait que peut-être que koivu
l'utilisons qu'on arrive à la fin
d'année avec tout ce que cela comporte
on a du mal à donner
écoutez moi je n'ai pas en discutant
avec les gens je n'ai pas l'impression
concernant la maladie que ce soit
octobre rose que ce sera la cause des
panneaux ou le sidaction je dirais que
tout le monde est sensibilisé par la
maladie quand on demande pour une autre
cause par ailleurs peut-être qu'il donne
loin mais concernant la maladie je crois
que vraiment les martiniquais ne sont
pas je vais dire
ils sont sensibles ne sont pas
insensibles pardonnez moi vous visé
exactement quels chiffres cette année
alors moi je dis que pour la force et et
nous avons fait 90 milles dernière j'ai
moins bien atteindre les 100 milles et
vul défis qui se profilent à l'horizon
malgré le temps je pense qu'il nous fera
l'honneur de revenir au soleil ce matin
jeudi qu' étant l'année des prouesses et
des défis je pense que nous atteindrons
facilement les 100 mille euros parce
qu'encore une fois je crois que les gens
se sont beaucoup mobilisé 1000 euros sur
les défis mais sur
global visé combien balle mais je dirais
qu'on vise trois cent mille euros je
vais rester
très bien la question que beaucoup de
personnes se posent que fait-on de
l'argent récolté est ce que la
martinique bénéficient de deux de cet
argent et comment cela se traduit mais
écoutez vous avez un
vous avez le camembert qui vous
expliquent l'utilisation de la hanche en
mai ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il ya
une bonne partie de la somme par exemple
vous avez sur 100 euros
87 euros qui sont réservées à la
recherche le reste c'est pour le social
la prise en charge quelle blague voilà
il on sort alors vous vous avez le peu
de vent c
ma prochaine question en termes de prise
en charge des malades est-ce que ça
s'améliore
mais je vais dire vous avez deux volets
sur la prise en charge à la martinique
vous avez l'association martiniquaise de
lutte contre les myopathies dans la
présidente c'est marie marguerite jolie
et vous avez le centre de référence
caribéen les maladies neurologiques et
neuromusculaires
ce sont des consultations d'enfants et
d'adultes et le centre dirigée par le
neurologue le docteur bilan d'une toque
turbulent ce que je veux dire pour
répondre à votre question ça s'est
amélioré dans la mesure où les malades
n'ont plus besoin de partir en métropole
les diagnostics se fait ici et même
quand il partira en métropole il ya la
prise en charge par l'afm contre bien au
niveau de la recherche justement où on
est deux des avancées il ya eu des
avancées significatives
j'ai envie de vous dire on en parle
énormément il y à des avancées
significatives puisque lorsqu'en
87 on a découvert quatre gènes
aujourd'hui plus de 6000 jeunes de
maladies génétiques sont identifiés et
en 86 on découvrait le gène responsable
de la myopathie de duchenne aujourd'hui
on a 29 essais de thérapie innovante qui
sont encore dans le monde pour cette
maladie dont neuf sont soutenues par
l'afm téléthon
en 87 vous avez le concept de la
thérapie génique qui émergeait à peine
aujourd'hui la thérapie génique a fait
l'objet de plus de 600 et c'est dans le
monde pour des maladies rares du système
immunitaire de la vision du sang du
cerveau mais aussi des maladies
fréquentes
en 30 ans 15 ans d'espérance de vie
gagny dont certaines maladies grâce à
une prise en charge médicale adaptée
donc on ne peut pas dire et je reviens
sur la myopathie de duchenne qui est une
myopathie qui touche une forme de
myopathie qui touche un garçon sur 3500
et au moment où je vous parle il y à une
expérimentation il ya une très belle
avancée et à une expérimentation qui va
passer au stade supérieur c'est-à-dire
sur les personnes
radiées tôt ça suscite beaucoup
d'espoirs ça suscite beaucoup d'espoirs
écouter l'objectif lorsque
il ya eu le premier il faut pas faux pas
je vais dire le téléthon va toujours
perdurer ne faut pas oublier que c'est
le combat de groupes de malades des
familles dont le président bara tall qui
est parti aux états unis vivent renan
pour voir comment ça se passait sur le
sol américain avec jerry lewis qui avait
son fils atteint de myopathie il est
revenu en métropole et c'est vraiment un
groupe de malades de famille de mme
allen qui ont lancé le téléthon bien sûr
ça a été un événement télévisuel parce
qu'il fallait absolument que les
français que le monde anti voile et
découvre la maladie et j'ai j'ai
l'habitude de dire qu'à partir du moment
à cet instant on a 1000 m o on a mis des
mots sur les maux des familles et à
partir de cet instant le combat à
continuer et il va perdurer pendant là
jusqu'à ce qu'on trouve la signification
du mot guérilla ça veut dire que cette
génération comme dit laurence thiennot
la présidente ne passera pas sans
connaître le cap signification du mot
guérir nous allons parler du défi parce
que le téléthon c'est aussi
majoritairement des défis et des filles
un peu partout autres qui ont commencé
depuis lundi
d'édifiant prison par exemple alors je
reviendrai sur le défi en prison de ce
que je veux dire c'est qu'il ya des
défis qui ont commencé avant le club de
rugby à à lancer des défis le
le 11 novembre et le 4 novembre des gens
et vous avez eu également les collégiens
de l'école du robert qui ont donné un
spectacle c'est dommage vous n'étiez pas
présent mais c'est un spectacle vraiment
un groupe musical qui vous la peine
d'être a tendance à présent sur les
autres défilent rassurez-vous parce que
france 2 on est partenaires quand même
du téléthon pour venir sur le défi en
prison chaque année les prises audio du
coeur comme tous les autres martiniquais
il donne il donne et il participe aussi
au défi donc ce sont des défis sportifs
la plupart mais il y en a qui pratiquent
des objets qui sont revendus vraiment
c'est d'ailleurs c'est très touchant ce
matin à 8h le parrain ronald tulle est
la marraine
se rend présent
sur ce matin au moment où je vous parle
il en a devant la prison et attendent la
gauche et donc défi en prison dit fier
aussi au niveau des écoles c'est
magnifique la mobilisation des enfants
parce qu'on aime à dire que le téléthon
c'est l'occasion justement pour les
enfants d'être acteur parce qu'il donne
si leurs dons personnels donc il ya plus
de 800 élèves qui sont attendus ce matin
au jardin au parc aimé césaire avec le
maire de la ville de fort de france vous
avez l'élue en charge madame blacks aux
dons qui organise également avec
l'association
de martiniquaise demio contre la
myopathie
avec ma religion et qui organise une
très très grande manifestation aux gens
d'aimer 6e adhérents va t on lit sur le
dernier défi parfum l'objectif y est
farcie difficile des motards également
ah oui les défis demeurent des moutardes
on n'en parle plus j'ai plutôt envie de
parler d'eux
je ne minimise pas parce que je sais que
le défi des motards tout le monde en
parle mais il y a des fissures la savane
avec monsieur défend this mais aussi
avec un jeune mathieu le toubib qui fait
un week end c'est à dire un réveil des
consciences et je veux aussi c'étaient
les df je vais situer les jeunes de mon
général du collège du lycée
professionnel ribanelli son amant
générale madame dos je vous remercie le
téléthon c'est aussi sur notre
entraîneur d'autres notre antenne plus
de 30 heures de direct sur le réseau
france télévisions je vous remercie mais
les martiniquais apprentis leur 14h fait
sonner le 36 le 36 37
merci vous êtes la coordinatrice du
téléthon pour lamartine je vous remercie
de m'avoir reçu
[Musique]